oh let me tell you what happened last
weekend and you know that this
particular cousin or friend is just
going to talk on and on and on and on
and never get to the point of what
happened
what is screenplay structure oh
very big question right um but
i would look at screenplay structure as
how you tell a story and depending upon
the kind of screenplay you're writing
the structure is different in general
we've all learned about three-act
structure in some way shape or form
um that three-act structure can then be
broken down into just two acts if you're
writing a half-hour multi-camera comedy
it can be spread out into four or five
or six acts if you're doing a one hour
drama but your half hour single camera
and your features are usually told in
three acts and if you want to break it
down and make it as simple as possible
your first act is your setup
it's giving me all the information i
need to know of why i am here
your second act is the journey to reach
the goal
and then your third act is what happened
now that i reached the goal right so
it's your resolution so you have your
setup your journey and your resolution
and so if you can understand that any
time we hear a story bedtime story
dr seuss what happened last weekend
we're all listening for the setup
the journey to success or failure and
then what happened after that so to me
that's like the simplest way of talking
about what structure is for a screenplay
i like how you broke that down because
when we think about let's say a family
friend or a bunch of friends getting
together telling a story about what
happened last weekend
it makes sense if they leave out
the second act that's but when we think
about a story that we're writing
we could i could see where things would
get convoluted yeah because you also
even if you don't understand story
structure
you feel it
so you have a cousin or a friend who
doesn't know how to tell stories right
so they come in and they go oh let me
tell you what happened last weekend and
you know that this particular cousin or
friend is just gonna talk on and on and
on and on and never get to the point of
what happened right
but amongst your friend friend group are
amongst your family they're like no no
no let such and such tell it
because you know such and such is going
to give you the setup
the journey
and what happened you know the
resolution you know that you're gonna
get there you know that they're gonna
give you the details that you need
nothing extraneous or they're gonna say
quick sidebar and then they'll give you
this extraneous stuff and then they'll
come back to the story and keep you
following the journey right so
storytelling is storytelling is
storytelling no matter where you're
telling it right um in a screenplay it
has to be more concise and it has to be
visual
but even those people who don't
specifically know they can't give you
the vocabulary they don't have the words
to explain
you know how to tell a story we're
hearing people tell stories all the time
you know like going back to that office
thing there's somebody in your office
who always stands around the kitchen or
whatever and they have a story
you know blah blah blah and you enjoy
their stories then there's somebody else
who always has a story and you're trying
to sneak away from the conversation
because you know you're going to be here
for the next 15 minutes and have learned
absolutely
nothing and so that's kind of how you
know that your screenplay isn't working
because we're 30 pages in and i don't i
don't have any information
we're 30 pages in and i don't know what
this screenplay is about we're 30 pages
in and i don't know why i've been
dropped into it right i don't know what
i'm here to witness because there's a
whole lot of talking and going around
the you know bin and over the river and
through the woods but i still having the
slightest idea what my protagonist is
trying to do or possibly who my
protagonist is in the first place
right so sometimes that happens um but
yeah storytelling is storytelling so if
we start to
allow and it's hard when you're the
writer right when it's on the page
because now there's all kind of pressure
and stress and stuff but if we allow
ourselves to step away from it and just
look at it like any kind of story we can
ask ourselves like does it feel like my
story is moving forward or does it feel
like people are just kind of talking
around
some things you know but that's why
again people like me exist because maybe
you can't see that yourself and i pride
myself on being objective my students
tell me all the time your objective
right i even had a student in one of my
classes on the university level who said
can you teach the rest of our teachers
how to be objective in this way because
when
i read their stuff i don't
make them become a particular kind of
writer i'm able to look at them as
individuals which means they write the
way that they write it's not my job to
make them fit into this box right but a
lot of the times you may send your work
out and what you receive back is a whole
lot of opinion about what your writing
should be and you should change this and
it should be this you should have that
blah blah and it's like well that's a
great story but that's not my story
that's not the one that i'm trying to
tell right so finding someone else who
can objectively look at your stuff they
can help to help you to understand that
your story is kind of going around in
circles and not pushing forward just
like when uncle such and such starts
telling a story you know whether it's a
drunken one or not right you know he's
never going to get to the point guys we
can go continue playing our basketball
game
right so when you say that um
you like to to work with people and and
find out the way they tell a story and
who they are
um
how like how is that because because so
somebody could say well this is just who
i am and i i don't really like to
formulate full sentences and i'm just
this is just my style yeah
is that acceptable if it's working
okay that's why you have to be objective
because sure
we can say i need full sentences
but if it's working if the fact that
they're shortening their sentences is
helping me to feel
the tone that they're setting helping me
to feel the urgency of the story i read
a screenplay the other day
and every single line of action was just
one sentence
but it made the story simple because it
was about a simple guy doing a simple
thing
i didn't need more right
but if this were a more
convoluted premise if it were a more uh
dramatic story where i needed to feel
more things etc then now my note would
be i need more right and here is why but
i was able to tell this particular
writer
usually i would say i need x y and z but
this is working for you
because i also want them to know the
rule
right i also want them to know someone
else might read this and say x y z
but it's working for you the same thing
is true with um i sometimes have people
who instill their voice too much as a
writer and so it's jarring right now i'm
hearing you and it's pulling me out of
the story
sometimes that works though
same thing with camera angles right it's
a no-no for writers to infuse camera
angles in their screenplay because it's
distracting to the read i'm into
something emotional then here you come
with big capital letters close in i
already know that i'm close
because i feel it because i'm reading
the story and now you just ruined it for
me by yelling close in as if the
director won't feel that from the
context that you've set up but then i
read somebody else's screenplay and they
didn't use it a lot but the moments that
they did
worked
it felt right it didn't pull me out so
that's what i mean by you have to be
objective to the story you have to
understand what is this story trying to
do what does it feel like what's its
tone what's its writer's voice what is
it intending to do and are they doing
that and if they are then why would i
tell them to take away the things that
are making that thing happen you know
so if we took let's say a young charles
bukowski in a writing program
and you know there's just one way to do
this and then he's presenting this work
that
might be you know might raise some
eyebrows but that's who he was that's
his style
and and maybe he just didn't find the
right teacher let's say yeah i mean
and you know the thing is not everyone's
a teacher
just because you know how to write
doesn't mean you know how to teach
people how to write that's just the
truth of it and i think we take the
whole we take the education part of it
uh
um
not seriously enough right um so maybe
that is the case because also teachers
are only teaching what they've been
taught depending upon how much
experience you've had in the industry
you may think it has to be this way
because i was taught it has to be this
way but if you're continuing to read
screenplays even as a professional
writer you'll see that people break
rules all the time people are doing
stuff all the time people make terrible
stuff that makes it onto tv and onto the
big screen all the time so why would i
tell my client that wouldn't work you
can't do that it's just not true you can
do anything you want now i'm going to
tell you what the industry standard
looks like i'm going to tell you what
people expect
but do you
because maybe it's going to work now
there are some things that you just
can't do like if it's if it's unreadable
then it's not going to work you know
what i mean if i can't follow the story
because of whatever risk you're taking
or creative licenses you're taking then
it's just not going to work but if i can
follow the story and i understand the
story a lot of those rules really do fly
out of the window they really do i'm
going to teach you what those rules are
but again if it's working then i'm not
going to stop you from doing the thing
that's working think about aaron sorkin
and how much dialogue are in his
screenplays we're told all the time you
can't have that much dialogue you can't
have that much dialogue think about
shonda rhimes and how many monologues
she has in her screenplays and we're
told all the time can't have monologues
can't have monologues we're here are two
examples where it's working very well
for these two people so i just don't
believe in
the extremes i don't believe in yes this
is gonna work and no that's not gonna
work because hollywood lives like in
that in between space and i think the
reason i can give that information is
because i have the experience to know
um and then also because i am a teacher
so i am trying to teach you to fish and
not giving you fish
right so i'm always going to give you
the why the how the possibilities the
what-ifs and sometimes that doesn't work
for people because they need to know
exactly what it is but i try to explain
to them hollywood is not one of those
places not black or white it really
isn't it's all that stuff in between so
you're trying to write a story that is
well executed that's that's doing what
you intended to do that you're going to
be proud of that represents you as a
writer because all of us are going to
look back on something that we wrote and
go oh my god that's terrible oh i can't
believe i wrote that so you're gonna
grow from it anyway so you just have to
get to a place where you're happy with
it
and it represents you so for someone
like aaron sorkin or even tarantito i'm
sure there were people telling them this
is too much dialogue i'm sure of it
but they were able to get in with
whichever way they got in because i
don't know their stories right but
however it is they got in and it worked
out for them
you